with the holiday season upon us it's a
good time to reflect on the things and
people for whom we are most grateful
in today's reporters notebook I'm giving
thanks to everyone who makes it possible
for us to roll out two hours of morning
television every day there are many ways
to prepare for Thanksgiving brine the
turkey chop the wood for the fire do the
research for the political fights you'll
have around the table I prepare for
Thanksgiving by making a list of the
things I'm grateful for it's based on an
essay from years ago by Roger Rosenblatt
it contains items big and small the New
Yorkers who texted us when they found
our lost dog Stumptown coffee roasters
at the top of my inventory this year are
the people you never get to see at CBS
this morning but whose work you see
every time you watch the show if there's
a piece you liked or a question that
helped you learn something or simply if
the show has become a part of your
morning it's these colleagues you have
to thank they interrupt their plans to
chase stories and bring you the people
at the heart of them they create entire
villages in random spots to bring you
live reports they capture just the right
shot and make sure the sound and light
Singh they sit in windowless edit room
solving a thousand puzzles under Harry
deadlines our news they stay up all
night as stories break while you sleep
to track information so we get it just
right and their graphics help make the
complex understandable let's rock and
let's roll they turn page after page of
scripts tweaking words sometimes until
just seconds before we say them they
make our hair and makeup and clothes
look just so in order for us to be at
our best for the crew that manages the
cameras cables and chaos during the live
broadcast
those of us in front of the camera work
hard to do work that is worthy of that
collective dedication so while you
gather around your table all those
you're grateful for we are grateful for
all those gathered around our table each
week and one final note of gratitude to
all of you out there watching thank you
and Happy Thanksgiving
John beautifully said and the words are
so true
we know who everyone favorite anchor is
here yeah well really that's what I was
fishing it for do you see because in a
copy that was so true very thankful for
everyone here